breaking news here on Sky News and we've
just heard that Nicola sturgeon has now
been released um she was of course
arrested earlier today by police
Scotland um I've got the statement here
in my hand in fact she was released just
20 minutes ago so this has happened
um just a few minutes ago it says the
investigation into Scottish national
party funding and finances update a 52
year old woman Nicholas sturgeon was who
was arrested earlier today Sunday the
11th of June as a suspect in connection
with the ongoing investigation into the
funding and financing of the Scottish
national party has been released without
charge she has been released without
charge pending further investigation it
goes on a report will be sent to the
crown office and pro-curator fiscal
service the matter remains active for
the purposes of the contempt of court
act 1981 and the public for advice to
exercise caution if discussing it on
social media warning of course from the
police there so Nicholas sturgeon
released Let's Go crossover live now to
Glasgow where our Scotland correspondent
Connor Gillies is there
um so Connor she spent the day speaking
to police today
seven hours or so of questioning for the
former first minister of Scotland Nicola
sturgeon brought in to face those
questions just after 10 o'clock this
morning we understand she presented
herself and was then arrested by those
officers when she turned up at that
police station released without charge
pending further inquiries within the
last couple of minutes this is an
investigation that has focused primarily
on the funding and the finances of the
SMP the governing party here in Scotland
a discussion over the course of the last
couple of years around six hundred
thousand pounds that was raised for the
cause of a second Scottish independence
referendum a second vote that has not
happened and there have been questions
around that cash today came the
crescendo in this investigation we've
had two arrests leading up to this
moment but then of course that webinars
of detention for Nicola sturgeon of
course this follows hot on the heels of
her the arrest of her husband the former
chief executive of the SNP Peter Morrow
he spent 12 hours in custody back in
April of this year those pictures at the
time showing those officers swarming the
property that they share on the
outskirts of Glasgow officers spent more
than 30 hours inside that home
Gathering collating bagging evidence and
have clearly spent the last number of
months piecing together and plotting
their next move that resulted in Nicola
sturgeon being arrested today and this
has been an investigation and this
moment from police in the last few
minutes has followed a pattern because
each of the arrests and of the suspects
in this long-running SMP probe each and
every suspect has been released without
charge pending further inquiries police
will now examine what they've heard
today from the mouth of Nicholas
sturgeon what was she telling them when
she was answering those questions they
will explore each and every word that
she said in custody while being detained
decide what they're going to do next if
anything as part of this investigation
but let's just take a step back this is
a huge moment for Scottish for British
Politics the former first Minister the
woman who who was in charge of Scotland
for more than 3 000 days the woman who
took Scotland and the UK by surprise by
announcing that shock resignation
earlier on this year something she said
had no part whatsoever in what she
called short-term pressure some issues
around transgender prisoners that she
was facing at the time and clearly this
police investigation that was operating
in the background during her Premiership
she was clear that that played no part
in that resignation and she said that
she would fully cooperate at any stage
if the police came knocking well clearly
that happened today on a Sunday morning
she was arrested just after 10 o'clock
she faced seven hours of questions that
culminated in her being released without
charge pending further inquiries
live in Scotland on the day Nicola
sturgeon was arrested and released
thanks very much indeed